I want to start with congratulations on
the movie oh thank you so much seriously
congrats thanks bro um so a ton of
questions but how tough was it coming up
with an authentic way for the two main
characters to meet how much did you
debate uh making because you know you
need to the audience needs to buy into
oh this is where people might actually
meet here I was telling Lauren that when
I talked to Jonah we we were just
riffing about stuff when we were going
back and forth and someone actually did
get it I had a black Mercedes and I was
waiting for someone and a white dude got
in the back of my car as an Uber and I
just was like At first I'm scared and
then I'm offended and then I'm but I was
like it's an interesting way for people
to meet you know I'm saying I kind of
think that it was also a fun way to sort
of to have that character sort of you
know it it had a lot of Social and a lot
of things because it was the social
aspect of it and she added that line
um about like you saw a black woman like
the idea of like how she that was her
improving she was right you know saying
like the idea of like there's a social
class thing to it like you just think
you can just I'm a black I'm I'm I'm an
inexpensive car and you're a white man
you can tell me what to do there also is
a Fear Factor as a woman a man hops in
your car I'm saying like that there also
was the moment that it gave levels
because when he
showed her you know the thing it sort of
there was a Twist and she was like okay
maybe and we didn't get a chance to show
but they're the original thing was they
drive around the city you know trying to
find a thing and there's like this great
conversation and he actually is spitting
you know shooting shooting his shot and
she kind of respects it because he's
funny and he's taking some taking some
chances so we felt like it was a really
sort of it gave us a lot it gave us like
where you could understand how these two
people could sort of like get to where
they were going and you know it was an
interesting sort of like we I hadn't
seen that before no I totally bought in
I was wondering how the how it was going
to go with you know the meeting but um
so I read could be wrong that you
actually didn't audition for this that
you were that you were offered yes
through my game she was begged she
wasn't offered she was begged
not true what was it like for you though
because it's not only are you getting
offered like a great role but you're
working opposite Jonah and Eddie which
is like are you effing kidding me um I
didn't know Eddie was attached to this
movie at first he wasn't at that point
yeah so um it was really
it wasn't even about that and they are
great people it was just like I just
wanted to make sure that I could
participate in this film in a real way
and you know and I think that's just in
our meetings and talking yeah
authenticity was the work that kept
coming up
it sort of influenced the rewrite I'm
saying is that we wanted this character
to feel authentic to a girl who grew up
Inglewood Baldwin Hills to a girl who
had these parents to a girl who was
experiencing this for the first time and
it really sort of helped shape you know
what it was for me so la plays a huge
part in this movie and deciding what
locations you wanted to use a huge part
like Roscoe's you know what I mean like
I could make a laundry list but what
would we also got to make sure we asked
him because that is a big part of our
100 which was the location that you like
no matter what this has to be in the
movie
um
it was like because that's like people
don't know about it and now there's like
this huge kick of like you know being
vegan or being alkaline or being like
just taking care of yourself green
juices and this and this is a black
owned business that's been in the
community for 20 plus 30. I think it's
like like I said but since the 80s since
the 80s you know what I'm saying and
been in the community and we know about
it and it's the idea that that was at
the heart of what we wanted this movie
to be is like things that can sort of
really say who we are but that now have
spread it out spread out past just that
black you know what we were doing also
the prices aren't that bad there they're
not have you and the food's amazing I
have not been but um I did anyway the
it's on my list but I I I checked it out
when you go get a tropical milkshake
with almond milk it is the best
milkshake you've ever had in your life
uh so I I definitely want to talk about
editing because ultimately that's where
everything comes together I apologize
it's a director question it's okay
she helped me no I didn't know I thought
her red and it was like so I am curious
how how did the film change in the
editing room in ways perhaps you were
not expecting so my editor is one of my
best friends her name is is Jamie and I
um Jamie Nelson and I I mean I've worked
on everything basically that I do
together and and she is a partner and we
you know we argue and fuss and fight but
it is like literally I believe that pain
editing is painting you know I'm saying
and you I didn't want to be in the room
and
um and for this movie we couldn't
because of for the first part of it we
got the lift but I went to Hawaii and we
edited it online and I was in Hawaii and
I was like literally can you go back
three frames can you do this can you at
this come out and she and we just we saw
it coming together and she fell in love
with Lauren and Jonah first and she went
in that sequence when they're walking
and talking over that amazing song and
it was like that was the heart to me of
the movie because like I wanted it to
feel like real and I wanted it to feel
like seamless and I think that editing
is the thing that I learned as a
showrunner that more directors need to
take part in a really really painstaking
way is every frame everything in that
frame every piece of music how the
coloring this that is it's everything I
also really liked your transitions thank
you yeah I thought those were really
well done I got to stop I'm just gonna
say congratulations thank you
congratulations I know you'll be making
another movie soon thank you so much for
sure